but there is also a part in the book
that discusses Michelle Obama's hair and
it seems to be a kind of a wish wishful
thinking at least then what would happen
if we talked about role models if
Michelle Obama went a bit more frizzy
you know why I wouldn't do intensive on
it I wouldn't call it going a bit more
frizzy I would call it if she stopped
the straightening yeah because the
frizzy but it's actually hard but that's
not the you know if if she stopped the
straightening it was something we shal I
mean it wasn't at all because I mean I'm
I really adore Michelle Obama I know and
and I would and for me she's an example
of a woman who a black woman who is very
keen to do she fits all the definitions
of mainstream black respectability after
straighten your hair and even the kids
now have to straighten their hair and
and I wonder are they doing it with a
relaxer with heat and I just and I worry
about how uncomfortable it must be for
the poor kids but I think for me really
was just a larger question of if
Michelle Obama had natural hair Barack
Obama would not have one did not have
one school I mean it's it's it's sad and
it seems shallow and but it is true
because particularly in America that all
of these assumptions attach to natural
black head Michelle Obama had dreadlocks
or an afro or corn rows
she might be thought to be radical Black
Panther difficult or a jazz singer oh
yeah well yeah and that that's also not
not good for president no no it's rather
shocking I mean we can make fun of it
but it's it's really sad I think it is
very sad I think it is very sad so you
have you have
for a black president but we're not all
there you can't be too black